Reggie Aloysius Miller called the
Thunder Rockets last night on TNT and
he's got the Grizzlies in the Spurs
coming up tonight at nine thirty eastern
on tnt already seen reaction here reg
you know that Westbrook proving he's not
the MVP based on last night I'm saying
oh my gosh I hope that we don't cap you
know a carp compartmentalised this and
say all of a sudden whoever plays well
or whoever advances is the MVP but what
do you take away from last night's game
between these two well certainly James
Harden has more weapons surrounding him
better shooters and a better fit for
players under head coach Mike D'Antoni's
system both are phenomenal and for all
the peoples as you alluded to that our
hating on Russell Westbrook number one
the vote 30 year it would be nice to
actually have a chance to watch players
throughout the playoffs and then do the
voting especially now this is the first
year that we're actually going to have
an award show I believe it's jun 26 so
actually you could watch all the
playoffs and then actually do your
voting for the MVP i would love to kind
of you know watch players during the
playoffs when it's money time when it
means the most but the votes are already
in so it doesn't really matter what
happens between russ and james and
defender and the Rockets because the
votes already end but i'm watching
Houston's team I don't know if they're
that much more talented than Oklahoma
City it's just they are better suited
for the system that Mike D'Antoni has
whereas Oklahoma City losses Kevin
Durant in a system that they had built
for years so it feels like they don't
have the system that Houston Houston has
a team system Oklahoma City has a
Russell Westbrook system well look right
now and really all season long the
Thunder have been a one-man band and
they've been that walking triple-double
in Russell Westbrook he needs shooting
and you know Victor Oladipo was one of
12 last night to me you know for them to
win this series and be successful in
this theory Westbrook was going to need
a wingman he was going to need another
guy who can create offense on his own
and who could make timely shots to me
Victor Oladipo has to be that guy they
don't have the shooting of a Ryan
Anderson or Lou Williams air Gordon
trevor ariza Patrick Beverley last night
was the x factor for the rocket and he
plated that both in he had to guard
Russell Westbrook it he you know had a
career playoff high in 21 points and you
look at the Thunder roster if Andre
Roberson is going to be your second
leading scorer guys are known for his
defense then you're going to have
problems night in and night out because
my dad Tony says we're going to treat
him like Vegas in the house money if he
makes shot we're just going to shake his
hand and lose he had a great game but he
can't be your second leading scorer all
George's comment he didn't take the last
shot against the Cavaliers CJ Miles did
he said afterwards I I should be taken
that last shot not I'm paraphrasing but
how did get to the point where Paul
George is not taking your last shot in
and as being a Hall of Famer how does it
work when it comes to that last shot
well there really it never is a pecking
order usually the best players do get
the last shot because the ball normally
ends up in their hands but let me
backtrack a little bit because he's
right in his comments he should be
taking the last shot he's absolutely
wrong by saying that publicly on the
dais after it after the game that's
something that should be handled
internally in the locker room you know
between the head coach and CJ Miles or
whatever the play was simple it was a
one-four flat but let's backtrack a
little bit okay they're down 10 5 10 9
they come down and run a simple high
screen roll where Paul George knocks
down the three to bring them within one
as you saw Tyrone and the Cavs did not
call a timeout and they wit with the
play where LeBron James mr.
three and the Pacers got the rebound and
called timeout what I have would have
liked and I think I believe Jeff Van
Gundy said this on the air they should
have went with the play right away they
didn't need to call a timeout because
what that timeout did it gave the Cavs
in tyrone tyronn lue a chance to set up
their defense too they knew Paul George
was going to take the shot so they had a
foul to give if you don't call a timeout
in that situation all those factors are
not discussed during that timeout so I
would have loved it seeing the Pacers
once they secured the rebound on 109-108
let Paul George go one-on-one there I
guarantee you they probably wouldn't
have thought of fouling which they had
that foul to give and on that very last
play LeBron James did the right thing
they came with a soft double on Paul
George's left side to things he did
right Paul George you have to give the
ball up that's the unselfish play but if
you do want to be selfish which you
could have been you should have attacked
junior Smith to his right when the Brawn
James because he saw mob Ron James
coming up on his left attack junior
Smith on his right that's where he could
have made the move and get a little bit
selfish if you wanted to last shot he
made the unselfish play and the right
play to give it up to CJ Miles there's
no way as soon as he gave it up you saw
him Kate after the bath balls there's no
way he would have got a great look off
going to his left turn catch the
basketball shooting back right I
understand the frustration because yes
you are supposed to take the last shot
when you're the best player but it
doesn't always work out that way I don't
like him saying that on the podium
afterwards because now if you're CJ
Miles you have to answer the question
and this is the guy that's never been
put in that position before especially
on in team basketball which that's what
basketball is we all got to take the hit
on that these Reggie Miller NBA on TNT
reg had Rockets Oklahoma City last 90 s
got Grizzlies in the Spurs coming up
tonight on TNT is this
call for the Clippers well I certainly
think so i think the window is closing
um but look look let's not jump off up
the tallest building quite yet it's only
one game no no notnot evening but not
not based on this serie you know if they
don't get out of this series then then
they'll dismantle this but I'm wondering
is this the last go-round no matter how
far they get in the playoffs unless they
get to the NBA Finals it feels like doc
is not going to be there and then
they're going to start to reassess you
know what the future I believe doc I
believe doc will be there I believe a
team will offer JJ money JJ redick a lot
of money no I believe he will be gone
now you've got to answer the question
can we retain Chris Paul and Blake
Griffin and to me those are the two main
questions let's leave doctor you're not
going to get a better head coach has
been Doc Rivers did the big question is
can can and and do both Blake and CP
three want to continue to play together
I believe JJ redick is gone I another
team will offer him a lot of money so
yeah I think the band is breaking up
with the Clippers no matter how far they
go but these are lofty expectations we
are asking the Clippers to do you know
the four or five matchup is always a
pick'em matchup and it looked like the
air got let out of the building when
Rudy Gobert went down it was almost like
the Clippers exhaled a little bit like
ah ok we're on easy street well give
quin snyder and the Jazz a lot of credit
for peace mailing that victory together
and that's why you brought in veterans
like George Hill and I so Joe Joe
Johnson for moments like this in the
playoffs so they still game one I always
thought this was going to be a dogfight
theory I still believe the Clippers can
win this series but now you're asking
them to win in the second round well
who's waiting for them in the second
round a team that beat their head in the
last nine times yeah and the gold if a
warrior the team with the best record
wait wait you call him I so Joe oh that
booty was called in Atlanta I so Joe
he balances he got 20,000 points reg he
does yeah and I ok my life away to wait
and and 210 million dollars in the bank
as well I'll take it and okay here's a
question for you who's hurt their
basketball legacy more while running a
team Michael Jordan or Phil Jackson Phil
jacquard okay bilge active look will
always think of the goat because the
goat has those six rings in six finals
MVP yeah the girls got a lemon he does
but he has rolled the back of a lot of
great players to get those 11 what is he
doing with the Knicks reg I have no idea
what if I'm Carmelo Anthony I've got to
feel great and let down by management
and my ownership I mean this is said
what Phil Jackson is doing to Carmelo
Anthony I would love to come on here and
just kill the Knicks and laugh and laugh
me coming from Indiana but I really do
feel for Carmelo Anthony because it's
not right what has gone on with him over
the last two years and if I was him I
would stick to my guns because I've got
the ultimate trump card the know Trey I
would I wouldn't accept whatever deal
they brought to me and force bill
Jackson to cut me that's what I would do
there's not going to be a deal where the
Knicks will get fair value in a trade
for Carmelo so just hold Pat and force
them to cut you there's no way that ill
do that cut them yeah yes sir yes there
is oh boy and I go back to my point who
wants to play for the Knicks when your
management is doing this to your best
player and then tells your second best
player you're not ready to take the
mantle in porzingis yes porzingis gets
the exit
because he's frustrated so if you are a
potential free agent on the wings
waiting and you maybe wanted to play for
the New York Knicks and you see what's
going on in management do I really want
to be a part of that nope nope yeah it's
a mess man a great don't get me wrong
New York is a great place to play
fabulous the fans are very knowledgeable
I loved playing to get them i love the
atmosphere playing in the garden but man
come on 80 and 160 six over three years
for phil jackson you tell me another
general manager president that would
still help have his job after that track
record unless in New York City oh yeah
but unless it was the seventy Sixers who
actually tell their fans were trying to
be bad the Nixon have paid money and
they're trying to be good and they're
bad so what was the Carmelo Anthony he
went out and signed Noah to that deal
was was it was it Carmelo Anthony he
went out and got Derrick Rose but also I
think the Knicks thought that mellow
could get free agents in there and I
wouldn't want to play with melo if I'm a
free agent so it's you know I think they
they overshot what they thought could
happen with melo that boy he's going to
get dream teamers to come in here and
you know there if he's a third option on
a team or a second option on the team
then that'll be great for mellow but i
know i don't want to build around him
and nobody's going to want to play with
melo in New York either well they tried
to build around him and that's why they
gave him the big contracting the
no-trade clause and they brought in you
know Noah and rose and they dropped they
drop it great in Coors ingots don't get
me wrong that was a great pickup I shall
Jackson but for whatever reason it has
not worked and that's not mellow mellow
doesn't have to be on the phone and call
all the free agents and say come play
with me that'sthat's them's [ __ ] job no
these guys talk all the time reg that's
what happened in Miami those guys got on
the phone and started talking to each
other and all of a sudden you get
together well if that's the case then
Golden State well then shouldn't LeBron
have been on the phone with Carmelo to
get him in
I'll bet he tried to they were talking
about Kevin Love for Carmelo that that
possibility we'll discuss this you know
what plenty of time to talk about the
next safe travels to the Grizzlies and
the Spurs Theodore you are truly and
always the best thank you so much for
having me all right buddy that's a
Reggie Aloysius Miller the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience